y
[Música]
el gobierno ruso informó que sus
objetivos militares en ucrania ya no se
centrarán únicamente en la región del
donbass mientras tanto quiet denuncia
que en slogans las tropas de rusia se
están reorganizando tendremos reporte de
nuestra enviada especial
el ex ministro de economía risas unac y
la ministra de exteriores listas serán
los candidatos finales a sustituir a
boris johnson al frente del partido
conservador y como primer ministro
británico johnson por su parte
protagonizó y su última sesión de
control en el parlamento
la asamblea legislativa de el salvador
extendió por un mes más el estado de
excepción en su denominada guerra contra
las pandillas la controversial medida ha
permitido al gobierno de nadie bukele la
captura de miles de pandilleros al
tiempo que ha generado denuncias por
violaciones a los derechos humanos
ampliamos
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos este informativo
con información sobre la guerra en
ucrania este miércoles el ministro de
asuntos exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov
aseguró que sus objetivos militares ya
no se centran únicamente en la región
del donbass y que las tareas geográficas
cambiaron el funcionario dijo además que
las conversaciones de paz en ucrania no
tienen sentido si
la geografía es diferente ahora ahora no
es sólo sobre el lugar idóneo sino
también la región de gerson la región de
saponis ya y varios otros territorios
por donde este proceso continúa
consistente y persistente y no estoy sur
al tiempo que labró pronunciaba estas
palabras el gobierno ucraniano aseguró
que las tropas del kremlin se están
reorganizando desde es lo bianco nuestra
enviada especial catalina gómez ángel
nos actualiza la situación
es lo de antes es una ciudad que está
atacada constantemente esta calle que
está a mis espaldas todas las
edificaciones tienen la fachada dañada y
este edificio el ladrillo era un colegio
pero este no es el único ataque ayer se
daba un ataque aéreo desde un avión uno
de los pocos que se han dado en la zona
del donbass donde los ataques suelen ser
con misiles y con artillería y es que en
la batalla se reactiva en esta zona y se
cree que las tropas rusas están
reagrupando para atacar esta ciudad que
después de cra motors sería la más
importante por esta zona de el donbass
sin embargo es interesante porque si en
mayo gran parte de la población se había
marchado un gran número regresó porque
pensaban que las condiciones eran
mejores o porque no tenían dinero para
vivir como desplazados en otras partes
de ucrania o en otros países a los que
habían emigrado sin embargo las
autoridades han prendido las alarmas
porque no solamente la guerra se acerca
sino que las condiciones de vida son muy
difíciles las personas tienen que venir
a lugares como estos
y sacar agua porque no hay en la ciudad
tampoco hay gas lo que hace que muchos
tengan que cocinar con leña en los
jardines
esta guerra sigue teniendo consecuencias
políticas en la unión europea la
comisión europea propuso un plan de
emergencia sobre el gas que consiste en
que los países del bloque comunitario
reduzcan en un 15% su consumo entre el
próximo primero de agosto y el 31 de
marzo de 2023 esto para prepararse ante
un posible corte del suministro por
parte de rusia las formas de hacerlo
serían bajando la temperatura de los
termostatos limitando la calefacción o
el aire acondicionado en edificios
públicos y ofreciendo incentivos a la
industria para que usen combustibles
alternativos cuando sea posible el
reglamento necesita aprobación final de
todos los miembros y las medidas son
voluntarias pero no se descarta que
algunas puedan ser obligatorias cuando
se detecte un grave riesgo de escasez de
gas el flujo de gas ruso ahora es menos
de un tercio de lo que solía ser por
ejemplo en la misma época del año pasado
mailings
y
rusia no se está chantajeando está
utilizando la energía como arma y por lo
tanto en cualquier caso si hay un corte
parcial e importante del gas ruso o un
corte total europa necesito estar lista
vamos a reino unido donde ya se conocen
los dos finalistas para sustituir a
boris johnson al frente del partido
conservador y como primer ministro
británico el ex ministro de economía-
risi es una aquí la ministra de
exteriores listas serán los candidatos
finales anteriormente nuestra
corresponsal en reinounido luisa pulido
nos contaba cómo fue el proceso quienes
son estos dos políticos y como prosigue
ahora la votación será una verdadera
batalla por reemplazar a boris johnson
la sorpresa de la jornada ha sido la
eliminación de penn inmortal quien
durante la semana pasada y está aparecía
como la gran favorita con ritchie sunat
pero las negociaciones de las últimas
horas le dieron el pase a la final a lis
tras la secretaria de asuntos exteriores
británica que se ha vuelto muy muy
popular dentro del partido su gestión en
la guerra contra rusia la guerra en
ucrania reach es una es un economista de
origen indio formado en los eeuu él y su
esposa aparece en la lista de las
personas más ricas del reino unido
entre tanto listas es diputada desde el
año 2010 tiene amplia experiencia en
diferentes cargos en el gobierno además
representa la derecha dentro del partido
conservador y aunque votó en contra del
president el 2016 es la garantía del
partido de que este se cumplirá y con
ella podría entonces ser la tercera
primera ministra mujer en la historia
británica ahora el turno es para las
bases del partido conservador unas
200.000 personas que tendrán que votar
hasta el 2 de septiembre en tres unas y
listas para el nuevo jefe del partido
conservador y por ende primer ministro
tanto zona como lista se inician durante
el verano estas seis semanas una gira
por todo el país para dar a conocer sus
propuestas
entonces ganar los votos necesarios para
convertirse en el nuevo o la nueva
primera ministra y en italia el primer
ministro mario draghi instó hoy al
parlamento a reconstruir su coalición de
unidad nacional tras la crisis causada
por su socio de gobierno el movimiento
cinco estrellas que lo llevó a presentar
su dimisión decisión que draghi
reconsideró hasta el pronunciamiento del
resto de partidos pese a ello le tendió
de nuevo la mano para abordar las
cuestiones de la coalición ahora son los
partidos de derecha y extrema derecha
quienes complican la situación para
draghi pues rechazan gobernar en
coalición con el 5 estrellas la crisis
estalló el pasado jueves cuando el
movimiento cinco estrellas no votó una
moción de confianza de su propio
gobierno lo que obligó a draghi a
plantear su renuncia rechazada más tarde
por el jefe del estado sergio matar el a
alitalia observe una cirugía de fachada
italia no necesita una estabilidad
superficial que desaparece ante medidas
difíciles italia necesita un nuevo pacto
de confianza tan sincero y concreto como
el que nos ha permitido cambiar el país
a mejor hasta ahora son los partidos y
ustedes los parlamentarios y partido
pues está disposta que esté tomando pues
está disposta a cueste toman están
listos para reconstruir este pacto están
listos están listos están listos para
confirmar ese esfuerzo que hicimos en
los primeros meses y luego se desvaneció
estamos aquí estoy aquí en esta cámara
sólo en este punto del debate porque los
italianos lo han pedido las respuestas a
estas preguntas no deben darme la a mí
sino deben dárselo a los italianos
gracias entenderá me matado y te daré a
tutti l'italiana gracias la asamblea
legislativa de el salvador extendió por
un mes más el estado de excepción en su
denominada guerra contra las pandillas
la controversial medida está vigente
desde el pasado 27 de marzo por un
aumento de la violencia homicida en el
país centroamericano lo que le ha
permitido al gobierno de nadie bukele la
capture de más de 46 mil pandilleros al
tiempo que le ha llovido denuncias por
miles de violaciones a los derechos
humanos para tratar este tema conectamos
con nuestro corresponsal en
centroamérica andrés suárez jaramillo en
ciudad de guatemala andrés en materia de
derecho es constitucional que el
congreso salvadoreño amplíe por una
cuarta vez más la medida de régimen de
excepción
hola rodrigo bueno justamente este es
uno de los puntos por los cuales está
siendo tan criticado internacionalmente
el concepto de democracia y es que esta
cruzada de nadie bukele y en contra de
eso de las pandillas tiene un eco una
resonancia una aprobación de parte del
congreso de una manera irrestricta la
respuesta es no porque el congreso solo
podría extender el estado de excepción y
el motivo por el cual fue decretado
inicialmente es estuviera replicando es
decir que si los más de 80 asesinatos
que se registraron un fin de semana en
marzo de este año se estuvieran
replicando a lo largo de los meses bien
podría el congreso extender el estado de
excepción pero no lo está haciendo lo
está haciendo bajo la justificación abro
comillas hasta encarcelar a todos los
terroristas de manera tal que el
congreso la asamblea con 67 votos a
favor 15 en contra 0 abstenciones
[Música]
el quinto mes en el estado de excepción
que es la fecha de aproximadamente
así que se espera llegar a la cifra de
son los pandilleros que tienen
registrados en el gobierno busquen en
sus estadísticas y andrés a medida que
avanza este estado de excepción y las
detenciones como bien has explicado
organismos de derechos humanos ahora
están recepcionando centenares de
detenciones arbitrarias de personas que
serían inocentes que actualización hay
al respecto
bueno ayer precisamente se pudo ver en
las calles de san salvador un grupo de
más de 200 familias dirigiéndose
marchándose marchando hacia la casa
presidencial de nadie bucle para
exigirle la liberación de sus parientes
que presuntamente fueron capturados
arrestados sin justa causa y además de
organizaciones de derechos humanos
presentaron un informe muy detallado
entre el grupo de trabajo de detenciones
arbitrarias de las naciones unidas donde
se detalla las represiones y las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
se estarían cometiendo en el salvador en
estos meses de estado de excepción y es
que se han recepcionado más de 2.200
denuncias de personas que habrían sido
capturadas de una manera ilegal es decir
uno sin los requisitos para llevar a
cabo esta captura y dos sin las
evidencias sin las pruebas prácticas de
la comisión de los delitos de manera que
con este informe se espera que el grupo
de trabajo detenciones arbitrarias de la
onu pueda realizar una visita oficial a
el salvador y pedirle y el que rinda
cuenta para que no se estén realizando
más violaciones de derechos humanos
andrés muchas gracias por ampliar nos
toda esta información desde guatemala
cambiamos de tema porque la misión de
las naciones unidas en afganistán
advirtió en un informe este miércoles
sobre la erosión de los derechos humanos
en el país desde la llegada de los
talibanes la organización hizo énfasis
especialmente en la situación de mujeres
y niñas que se ven relegadas ahora al
ámbito del hogar asimismo mostraron
preocupación por la impunidad de
miembros de los talibanes que podrían
haber realizado ejecuciones
extrajudiciales de personas acusadas de
formar parte de grupos armados
y acabamos en sri lanka donde el
parlamento eligió al ex primer ministro
rajiv y créeme singer presidente para
sustituir a gotabaya rajapaksa quien
huyó y renunció en medio de una fuerte
crisis política y económica según los
resultados oficiales me cree me singer
quien ha sido seis veces primer ministro
recibió 134 votos contra 82 en el
legislativo con la elección de be creeme
singer de 73 años el actual gabinete
queda automáticamente disuelto y se
elegirá un nuevo primer ministro pero el
cambio no convence a los manifestantes
que pedían su dimisión y que amenazan ya
con seguir en las calles veamos en el
siguiente informe cuál es el contexto de
la crisis multidimensional en sri lanka
estas imágenes han dado la vuelta al
mundo el 9 de julio tras meses de
protestas por la peor crisis económica
desde la independencia de stri lanka los
manifestantes tomaron la residencia del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa y lograron
lo que están pidiendo en la calle desde
marzo que anunciará su dimisión
este debería ser el día más feliz de
nuestra vida porque el presidente no
robo robo en nuestro país no es cuánta
gente está caminando afuera todavía no
hemos ganado no podemos recuperar su
dinero pero somos las personas más
felices creo que hablo en nombre de todo
el mundo en este país
los manifestantes exigieron a rajapaksa
que asumiera la responsabilidad por la
escasez de medicamentos alimentos
electricidad y combustible que puso de
rodillas a la otra rica economía sur
asiática desde finales del año pasado y
provocó la miseria de los ciudadanos
según el programa mundial de alimentos
casi 5 millones de personas lo que
corresponde al 22 por ciento de la
población necesitan ayuda alimentaria
no sólo podemos comprar unos 250 gramos
de pescado y a veces es solo un pescado
[Música]
tenemos que cortarlo en muchos trozos
pequeños para que todos los miembros de
la familia puedan comer como no tenemos
mucho dinero a veces estamos el pescado
a los niños y nosotros sólo comemos la
salsa con una deuda de más de 51
millones de dólares a prestamistas
extranjeros el nuevo presidente tendrá
que seguir las negociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional- un paso
esencial para dar alguna esperanza de
futuro a los 22 millones de stri langues
es
y así terminamos este repaso informativo
a la actualidad internacional sigan
conectados con nosotros en france 24 y
en nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]